THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER. AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES AS
CHAU.
CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI A. KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DIAL THE. DAILY.
EIGHT MEN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GLORIA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GRAY. GRACE EN
HARPER. HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUICKSILVER THAT.
RAY ENDS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE CHAMBER.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD IS
MARKED BY AREAS WHERE COUNTRIES
HAVE BEEN RULED. BY MONARCHS
KINGS AND EMPERORS.
THE OFTEN CLAIMED DELINEATES
CONFIRMED BY DIVINE SELECTION.
BUT FEW OF THEM HAVE BEEN
REMEMBERED FOR VERY LONG.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
AGO TRUNKS TO REFLECTING ON WHAT
WOULD BE BEST FOR CHINA SAID.
ONLY ONE WHO HAS NO USE FOR THE
EMPIRE IS FIT TO BE ENTRUSTED
WITH IT.
HE WAS SAYING THAT ONLY ONE
WITHOUT SELFISH MOTIVES SHOULD
BE ENTRUSTED WITH THE GREAT
RESPONSIBILITIES OF GOVERNING
LEADERSHIP.
THE WISDOM OF OUR SPIRITUAL
VISIONARIES AND POETS. WHOSE
WORDS FLOWED FROM THE HEART OF
OUR SHARED HUMANITY REMAINS
UNIVERSAL.
THEIR INSIGHTS ARE TIMELESS AND
CROSS ALL LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL
BARRIERS.
AND ALL THAT ALTHOUGH CENTURIES
MAY SEPARATE IF
THEIR WORDS ARE REMEMBERED AND
ADMIRED.
A PERSIAN SPIRITUAL POET RUMI
SAID.
WHEN WE STOP ADMIRING OURSELVES.
AND LET THE EYES OF THE HEART
OPEN AUDITION.
THEN ALL WE DO WILL BECOME
ADMIRABLE.
SO SIMPLE.
WHEN WE STOP ADMIRING OURSELVES
THEN ALL WE DO WILL BECOME
ADMIRABLE.
ARROGANCE AND SELFISHNESS ARE
THE SEEDS OF DIVISION AND
HATRED.
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
ARE THE SEEDS OF HOPE AND
HARMONY.
NOW MORE ARMENIA.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
PLEASE FLIGHT PLEASE UP FACE THE
FLAG PUT YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER
YOUR HEART.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BATES.
INDIVISIBLE VARIATION. RAW.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JANUARY
ELEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS
TELEMEDICINE AND
ON NO BRIAN DAHLE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FIRST DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHEAPER  DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK MISTER BONTA MOVES AND
MISTER DALI SECONDS OF THE.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL SOME BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTIONS AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF.
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES ALL ABSENCES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED THE
JOURNAL.
IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY DONE SO
PLEASE SILENCE YOUR CELLPHONE AT
THIS TIME MISTER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A AND ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR. IN
THE GALLERY AND AT THE ROSTRUM
FOR THE GOVERNOR STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE REQUEST IS GRANTED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR THE
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT FOR
THE AMENDMENTS TO S. B. FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT. TO BE DEEMED
ADOPTED AND ORDERED OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
WE WILL NOW RECESS THE REGULAR
SESSION AND CONJOINT CAN CONVENE
THE JOINT CONVENTION.
EVERYONE PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
IS IN THE CHAMBER.
I AM A POINT YOU KNOW JOINT
COMMITTEE TO ESCORT GOVERNOR TO
THE ROSTRUM. PLEASE RETIRE TO
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AS YOUR
NAME IS CALLED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CABALLERO.
CARILLO.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
DALAI.
IRWIN.
AND THURMOND.
SENATORS BELL.
GALGIANI.
HERNANDEZ.
JACKSON.
LARA AND NEWMAN
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE
WELCOME THE THIRTY NINTH
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE HONORABLE EDMUND
G. BROWN JUNIOR
WE HAVE SEVERAL OTHER HONORED
GUESTS HERE TODAY AS WELL.
PLEASE WELCOME THE FIRST LADY
AND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO THE
GOVERNOR. AND GAS BROWN
.
PLEASE ALSO WELCOME THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER.
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR.
ATTORNEY GENERAL HODIERNA SARAH.
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX PADILLA.
STATE TREASURER JOHN CHIANG.
STATE COMPTROLLER THAT HE.
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
TOM TORRE MIX AND.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER DAVE
JONES.
FROM THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
CHAIRWOMAN DIANNE.
MEMBER GEORGE RUNNER.
MEMBER SHARON WARDEN.
AND MEMBER FIONA MA.
ALSO JOINING US TODAY ARE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES PLEASE WELCOME THE
CHIEF JUSTICE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
TINY COUNTY OSAKA AWAY
.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE MEAN KID.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE CAROL
CORRIGAN.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE GOODWIN LIU.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE MARIANAO
FLORENTINO Y. ARE.
AND ASSOCIATE JUSTICE LEON
RECRUIT.
I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME OUR
CONSULAR CORPS REPRESENTINGA
NUMBER OF COUNTRIES THAT WE HAVE
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH.
WELCOME.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE WELCOME ALL
OTHER DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND SPECIAL GUESTS WHO
HAVE JOINED US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY.
IT IS QUITE AN HONOR TO BE PART
OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S SIXTEENTH
AND FINAL. WE THINK.
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
YEAH I'M ASSUMING IT'S THE FINAL
ONE.
BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO COULD
CONVINCE VOTERS TO EXTEND TERM
LIMITS ADDS IT'S OUR GOVERNOR.
HE SAYS HE'S DONE AUTO.
I WANT I THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP I KNOW WE'VE HAD
A I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER GREAT YEAR.
IT IS ALSO THE LAST STATE OF THE
STATE FOR SENATE PRO TEM. LEADER
KEVIN DE LEóN.
THE GOVERNOR PRO TEM AND I HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED QUITE A BIT
TOGETHER OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PAST. FEW YEARS AND I WILL DO
THAT WE'RE GONNA ALL MISS
WORKING TOGETHER MOSS A VERY
EXCITED BE WORKING. WITH OUR OUR
NEXT
PRO TEM FORMER ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE TONY ACTIVITIES.
BUT NO PLEASE WELCOME PRETEND
KEVIN DE LEóN.
THANK YOU MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES
FRIENDS FAMILY AS WELL AS FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE SO MUCH TO
BE PROUD OF
SO MUCH TO BE THANKFUL YET WE
ALL KNOW COLLECTIVELY WHAT
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN.
WE HAVE STILL MUCH WORK TO DO
WITHOUT QUESTION.
I WANT TO OFFER MY DEEPEST AND
MY SERIES THE SINCEREST
APPRECIATION.
TO QUITE FRANKLY WHY CALLED THE
GREATEST GOVERNOR IN UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN.
FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE.
BECAUSE UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP AND
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF
SPEAKER AS WELL AS MYSELF AND
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER HERE.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
CHAMBER AS WELL AS THE SENATE.
BUT SPECIFICALLY. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP.
WE OVERCAME THE WORST RECESSION.
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
IT'S NINETEEN TWENTY NINE.
THAT'S NO EASY FEAT AND THE
LARGEST STATE IN THE UNION.
AND NOW WE STAND ON FIRM
FOOTING.
READY TO CONFRONT THE CHALLENGES
THAT LIE AHEAD OF US.
AND ADVANCE IN OUR GREATEST
ASSET
WHICH WE ALL KNOW. THESE ARE
HUMAN ASSETS.
WHICH ARE OUR PEOPLE THE
CITIZENS OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I CAN SAY THIS UNKNOWN YOU HEARD
THIS AD NAUSEUM FOR ME.
THAT I'VE NEVER BEEN PROUDER TO
BE A CALIFORNIA.
TODAY WE FIRST TO DEFEND OUR
STATE AS WELL AS OUR NATION'S
HIGHEST IDEALS AND VALUES.
THERE'S BEEN MIGRATED SADDAM.
MY GREAT HONOR TO LEAD.
OF MY LIFE TO LEAD THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
TO MY COLLEAGUES BOTH DEMOCRATS
AS REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE.
YOU ARE THE GREATEST AND WHAT I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
FORGED TOGETHER.
SPEAKER RENDON WORKING TOGETHER
WE HAVE ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHED
QUITE A BIT UNLIKE ANY OTHER
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THE COUNTRY.
OCCLUDING WASHINGTON%
WHAT WE HAVE DONE TOGETHER ON A
WHOLE VARIETY OF ISSUES.
CAN BE MEASURED AT ALL.
AND TO THE GREAT GOVERNOR.
THE GREATEST STATE IN THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
AGAIN
IT'S BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER. US
SPEAKER RENDON.
SPEAKER TONI ATKINS WOULD CHOOSE
THIS BECAUSE WELL WHO I'VE
WORKED WITH OF WHEN I WAS A
LEADER AND THE LEADER SENATE AS
WE WORK TOGETHER.
IT'S BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
FORGED TOGETHER QUITE FRANKLY
HAS MADE HISTORY.
TOGETHER WE'RE SECURING A BETTER
FUTURE.
THE GREATEST STATE.
IN THE UNION THE GOLDEN STATE
OUR STATE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NOW IT
IS MY HONOR PLEASE WELCOME OUR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GENERAL
GAVIN NEWSOM.
WHAT'S THE. TAKE ME ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS TO FIGURE OUT.
DON'T COME TO THESE THINGS TO
LISTEN TO THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
SO IT'S A IN THE SPIRIT OF
BREVITY.
THANKFULLY CRACKED.
I.
IN THE SPIRIT OF BREVITY LET ME.
.
LET ME QUOTE JERRY.
GARCIA.
BUT THE GRATEFUL DEAD THE ONLY A
AN EX MAYOR. OF SAN FRANCISCO
POSSIBLY GET AWAY WITH THAT.
NOT WHO I THINK SAID SOMETHING
THAT REALLY PERSONIFIES THIS
HISTORIC MOMENT HE SAID YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE THE BEST OF THE
BEST.
YOU WANT TO BE THE ONLY ONE.
THAT DOES WHAT YOU DO.
I THINK THAT'S A WONDERFUL WAY.
OF DESCRIBING.
OUR GOVERNOR.
SO IT'S IN THAT SPIRIT.
THIS HISTORIC MOMENT.
IN OUR STATE.
AND IN THE LIFE OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY MAN THAT I'M PROUD
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU THE ONE. THE
ONLY SU WEEKENDS.
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JR
WELL.
AS MY FATHER USED TO SAY.
I ACCEPT THE NOMINATION
I'M
HERE REPORT PUT.
CALIFORNIA IS PROSPERING.
WELL IT FACES
CHAIR OF DIFFICULTIES WE SHOULD
NEVER FORGET THE BONY AND AND
THE ENDLESS OPPORTUNITIES
BESTOWED ON THIS SPECIAL PLACE
OR THE DISTANCE WE'VE ALL TRAVEL
THESE LAST FEW YEARS. HAS NO
HARD TO VISUALIZE OR EVEN
REMEMBER. THE HARDSHIPS
THE BANKRUPTCIES
IN THE HOME FORECLOSURES SO MANY
EXPERIENCE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION.
UNEMPLOYMENT WAS ABOVE TWELVE
PERCENT.
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR JOBS.
THE DEFICIT WAS TWENTY SEVEN
BILLION IN TWENTY ELEVEN.
THE NEW YORK TIMES.
THEY CALL THIS THE COAST OF
DYSTOPIA.
THE WALLSTREET JOURNAL SAW THE
GREAT CALIFORNIA EXES.
THE ECONOMIST THE LONDON
PRONOUNCED US.
THE UNGOVERNABLE STATE.
IN THE BUSINESS INSIDER SIMPLY
SAID.
CALIFORNIA IS DOOMED.
EVEN TODAY YOU'LL FIND CRITICS
WHO PLAY WHO CLAIM THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM IS DEAD. BUT
I'M USED TO THAT BACK IN MY
FIRST TERM A PRESTIGIOUS SUPPORT
SOLIS THE CALIFORNIA THE WORST
BUSINESS CLIMATE IN AMERICA.
IN POINT OF FACT PERSONAL INCOME
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MY
FIRST YEAR AS GOVERNOR WAS ONE
HUNDRED. AND FIFTY FOUR BILLION.
TODAY IT IS GROWN TO TWO POINT
FOUR TRILLION.
IN JUST THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
ALONE CALIFORNIA'S PERSONAL
INCOME HAS GROWN EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE BILLION.
AND TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION NEW
JOBS HAVE BEEN CREATED.
VERY WELL WORLD CAN MATCH THAT
GROWTH.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING HAS RISEN SO HIGH.
THAT CONTRAST SHARPLY WITH THE
ABYSMAL APPROVAL RATINGS GIVEN
TO THE U. S. CONGRESS.
CERTAINLY OUR ON TIME BUDGET SO
WELL RECEIVED THANKS IN LARGE
PART TO LOWERING THE TWO THIRDS
VOTE TO A SIMPLE MAJORITY TO
PASS THE BUDGET.
BUT PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IS ALSO
BUT INSPIRED BY YOUR PASSING
WITH BOTH REPUBLICANS IN
DEMOCRATIC VOTES.
PENSION REFORM.
I DON'T MINIMIZE THAT THAT WAS A
BIG PENSION REFORM MAY NOT BE
THE FINAL ONE BUT IT WAS THERE
AND YOU DID REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
YEAH WHOSE COMPENSATION REFORM
ANOTHER VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS THERE THE WATER
BOND. THE RAINY DAY FUND AND THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
AND BY THE WAY.
YOU REPUBLICANS AS I LOOK OVER
HERE LOOK OVER THERE DON'T
WORRY.
I GOT YOUR BACK.
ALL OUR BIG
ALL THESE PROGRAMS A BIG A VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR FUTURE
AND THERE PASSAGE DEMONSTRATES
THAT SOME AMERICAN GOVERNMENTS
ACTUALLY CAN GET STUFF DONE.
EVEN IN THE FACE OF DEEPENING
PARTISAN DIVISION.
THE RECENT FIRES A MUD SLIDE
SHOWS HOW MUCH WE'RE ALL
AFFECTED BY NATURAL DISASTERS
AND HOW WE CAN RISE TO THE
OCCASION. THE LOCAL LEVEL THE
STATE LEVEL IT WITH MAJOR HELP
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK ALL
THE FIREFIGHTERS THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THE VOLUNTEERS
.
THESE GREAT MEN AND WOMEN IT'S
THE GOAL TILT THEIR FELLOW
NEIGHBORS
SOME CASES
EVEN WHEN THEIR OWN OWN HOMES
WERE BURNING.
THERE WE SEE AN EXAMPLE OF
PEOPLE WORKING TOGETHER
IRRESPECTIVE OF PARTY.
PRESIDENT SELFLESS GIVING
CALIFORNIA SUBSTANTIAL
ASSISTANCE AND THE CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERSHIP IS NOW SPONSORING
LEGISLATION HELP CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THE OTHER STATES HAVE
SUFFERED MAJOR DISASTERS TEXAS
FLORIDA. AND THE COMMONWEALTH
REPORTER RICO.
IN THIS REGARD. WE SHOULD NEVER
FORGET OUR DEPENDENCE ON THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES IT
PRESENTS TO THE WAY WE LIVE.
WE CAN'T FIGHT NATURE WE HAVE TO
LEARN HOW TO GET ALONG WITH HER
I WANNA SAY THAT AGAIN WE CAN'T
FIGHT NATURE WE HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO GET ALONG WITH. AND
THAT'S NOT SO EASY FOR THOUSANDS
OF YEARS THIS LAND NOW CALL
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED NO MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND THEY DID
THAT FOR THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
SOME PEOPLE SAY AS LONG AS
TWENTY THOUSAND YEARS TODAY
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE LIVE IN THE
SAME PLACE. AND THE SHEER IMPACT
ON THE SOILS THE FORESTS AND THE
ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM HAS NO LONG
TERM PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO INNOVATE
CONSTANTLY AND CREATE ALL MANNER
OF SHELTER MACHINES A CREATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WILL CONTINUE. BUT ONLY
WITH EVER GREATER PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
THE DEVASTATING FOREST FIRES IN
THE MUD SLIDES ARE PROFOUND AND
GROWING CHALLENGE.
EIGHT OF THE STATE'S MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES HAVE OCCURRED.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
LAST YEAR'S THOMAS FIRE IN THE
TOUR AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES
WAS THE LOOK OF THE LAW LARGEST
IN RECORDED HISTORY.
THE MUD SLIDES THAT FOLLOWED
WERE AMONG THE MOST LETHAL THIS
STATE HAS EVER ENCOUNTERED.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD THE
HIGHEST AVERAGE SUMMER
TEMPERATURES IN RECORDED
HISTORY.
OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE SEASON HAS
INCREASED SEVENTY EIGHT DAYS IN
SOME PLACES.
NEARLY YEAR ROUND.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE READY WITH THE
NECESSARY FIRE FIGHTING
CAPABILITY AND THE COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS TO WARN RESIDENTS OF
IMPENDING DANGER.
WE ALSO HAVE TO MANAGE OUR
FORESTS AND OUR SOILS MUCH MORE
INTELLIGENTLY TOWARD THAT END
ALL CONVENE A TASK FORCE.
COMPOSED OF SCIENTISTS AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE FOURS
PRACTITIONERS TO YOU THOROUGHLY
THE WAY OUR FORESTS ARE MANAGED.
AND SUGGEST WAYS TO REDUCE THE
THREAT.
A DEVASTATING FIRES.
THEY'LL ALSO CONSIDER HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN INCREASE
RESILIENCY IN CARBON STORAGE
CAPACITY.
TREES IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ABSORB CO TWO NOT GENERATE HUGE
AMOUNTS OF BLACK CARBON AND
GREENHOUSE GASES HE DO TODAY
WHEN FOREST FIRE RAGES ACROSS
THE LAND.
DESPITE WHAT IS WIDELY BELIEVED
BY SOME OF THE MOST POWERFUL
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON.
THE SCIENCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE IS
NOT IN DOUBT.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF
SCIENCE OF EVERY MAJOR COUNTRY
THE WORLD INCLUDING RUSSIA AND
CHINA. HAVE ALL ENDORSED THE
MAINSTREAM VIEW THE HUMAN
BECAUSE GREENHOUSE GASES ARE
TRAPPING HEAT. IN THE OCEANS AND
THE ATMOSPHERE AND THE ACTION
MUST BE TAKEN TO AVERT
CATASTROPHIC CHANGES AND
AWAITING SYSTEMS.
ALL NATIONS AGREE EXCEPT ONE.
AND THAT IS SOLELY BECAUSE A ONE
MAN.
OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE FOLLOW A
DIFFERENT PATH IN LIFE BY TOP
SCIENTISTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA STANFORD AND CAL
TECH.
AMONG OTHERS OUR STATE HAS LED
THE WAY.
NUMEROUS JUST TELL BUILDING
APPLIANCE EFFICIENCY STANDARDS
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY REACHING
FIFTY PERCENT IN JUST A FEW
YEARS.
A POWERFUL LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD. INCENTIVES FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
AMBITIOUS POLICIES TO RETORT
WRIST REDUCE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS LIKE METHANE AND
BLACK CARBON. A UN SPONSORED
CLIMATE SUMMIT THIS SEPTEMBER IN
SEVEN CISCO AND THE NATION'S
ONLY FUNCTIONING AND
COMPREHENSIVE CAP AND TRADE
SYSTEM.
I'LL SURELY PROVIDE AN
EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR THE
REVENUES THAT THE CAP AND TRADE
AUCTIONS AND GENERATE.
YOU'RE RENEWING THIS PROGRAM ON
A BIPARTISAN BASIS WAS A MAJOR
ACHIEVEMENT AND WILL ENSURE THAT
WE WILL HAVE SUBSTANTIAL SUMS TO
INVEST IN COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS
THE STREET. BOTH URBAN AND
AGRICULTURAL.
THE GOAL IS.
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN FORUMS
HEALTHIER OUR VEHICLES CLEANER
ZERO MISSION THE SOONER THE
BETTER. AND ALL OUR TECHNOLOGIES
INCREASINGLY LOWERING THEIR
CARBON OUTPUT.
TO MEET THESE AMBITIOUS GOALS
WILL NEED FIVE MILLION ZERO
EMISSION GOAL VEHICLE EMISSION
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE.
BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE THREE AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TODAY SO WE ALL
GOT A LOT OF WORK.
AND.
OKAY.
THE BILL OF THE JOBS
AND IT'S CLEANER OR RURAL BE
THEN.
WHEN YOU PASS THE CAP AND TRADE
LEGISLATION YOU ALSO PASSED.
THE FAR REACHING AIR POLLUTION
MEASURE THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME
FOCUSES ON POLLUTANTS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
SPECIFIC NEIGHBORHOODS INSTEAD
OF JUST MEASURING POLLUTANTS
OVER VAST SWATHS IRWIN.
REGULATORS WILL ZERO IN ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHICH A PARTICULAR
DISADVANTAGE Y. TRAINS TRUCKS OR
FACTORIES.
MOON WITH CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER
IS A FUNDAMENTAL GOOD THE MUST
BE PROTECTED AND MADE AVAILABLE
ON A SUSTAINABLE BASIS.
WHEN DROUGHT SICKER CONSERVATION
MEASURES BECOME IMPAIRED.
IN RECENT YEARS YOU'VE PASSED
HISTORIC LEGISLATION TO MANAGE
CALIFORNIA'S GROUNDWATER WHICH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING. IT ADDITION YOU
PASSED IN MORE THAN TWO THIRDS
OF THE VOTERS APPROVED A WATER
BOND THAT INVESTS IN SAFE
DRINKING WATER CONSERVATION AND
STORAGE.
AS A RESULT WILL SOON BEGIN
EXPANDING FUN FUNDS ON SOME OF
THE STORAGE WE'VE NEEDED FOR
DECADES.
WHAT IS THE CLIMATE CHANGES AND
MORE WATER ARRIVES AS RAIN?
STILL THE SNOW.
CRUCIAL THE REAL THE CATCH OF
THE CAPTION THE OVERFLOW A
TIMELY AND RESPONSIBLE WAY.
THAT TOGETHER WITH THE RECYCLING
AND RAIN WATER RECAPTURE WILL
PUT US IN THE BEST POSITION TO
USE WATER WISELY. AND THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY POSSIBLE.
WERE ALSO RESTORING THE
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
WATERSHEDS PROTECT WATER
SUPPLIES IMPROVES CALIFORNIA'S
OUR A CLINIC SALMON RUNS.
FINALLY.
ONLY WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
WATER FIX
ALONG STUDY IT CAREFULLY
DESIGNED PROJECT TO MODERNIZE
OUR BROKEN WATER SYSTEM.
I'M CONVINCED THAT WILL CONSERVE
WATER PROTECT THE FISH.
AND THE HABITAT MEDILL TO INSURE
THE DELIVERY A BADLY NEED WATER
TO THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND ON CALIFORNIA'S ACTOR
DUCKS.
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS IN BOTH
THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH ARE
PROVIDING THE LEADERSHIP IN THE
FINANCING. BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IT'S VITAL FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND FOR THE WHOLE STATE THAT'S
TRUE THAT'S WHY. AND THAT'S THE
REASON WHY I PERSIST.
OUR CURRENT ME.
THE SIXTH LARGEST IN THE WORLD
DEPENDS ON MOBILITY.
WHICH ONLY A MODERN AND
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM PROVIDES.
THE VOTE ON THE GAS TAX WAS NOT
EASY.
BUT IT WAS ESSENTIAL GIVEN THE
VAST NETWORK IN ROADS AND
BRIDGES WHICH CALIFORNIA
DEPENDS.
AND THE ESTIMATED SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF CARS AND
TRUCKS TRAVEL OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY BILLION MILES A YEAR.
THE SUN'S ONLY NINETY THREE
MILLION MILES AWAY.
THE FUNDS THIS BE ONE MAKES
AVAILABLE ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAINTAIN OUR ROADS AND TRANSIT
SYSTEMS IN GOOD REPAIR.
TWENTY FIVE OTHER STATES HAVE
REYES GAS TAXES EVEN THE U. S.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THIS GOAL
FOR FEDERAL GAS TAX. BECAUSE THE
HIGHWAY TRUST FUND IS NEARLY
BROKE.
GOVERNMENT DOES WOULD
INDIVIDUALS CARE TO LIKE BUILD
ROADS AND BRIDGES AND SUPPORT
LOCAL BUS. AND LIGHT RAIL
SYSTEMS.
THIS IS OUR COMMON IN DENVER.
BUT WHICH WE POOL OUR RESOURCES
THROUGH THE PUBLIC SECTOR
IMPROVE ALL OF OUR LIVES.
FOR ANY GAS TAX MAY APPEAR TO BE
GOOD POLITICS.
BUT IT IS.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO DEFEAT ANY REPEAL EFFORT THE
GETS ON THE BALLOT YOU
.
LOOK.
LOOKING FOR THAT ONE REPUBLICAN.
BRAVE UPGRADE.
ALRIGHT SINCE I TALKED ABOUT
TOTALS IN TRANSPORTATION
I'LL BRING UP ONE MORE ITEM OF
INTEREST.
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
LARA.
I MAKE NO BONES ABOUT IT. I LIKE
TRAINS I LIKE HIGH SPEED TRAINS
EVEN BETTER.
SO DO THE VOTERS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN THEY APPROVE THE BOND
LOOK.
ELEVEN OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE HIGH
SPEED TRAINS THEY'RE NOT TAKEN
FOR GRANTED ALL OVER EUROPE IN
JAPAN AND IN CHINA.
PRESIDENT REAGAN HIMSELF SAID IN
JAPAN ON NOVEMBER ELEVENTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THE FOLLOWING I QUOTE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS PLANNING TO
BUILD THE RAPID SPEED TRAIN THAT
IS ADAPTED FROM YOUR HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL POETRY.
YES WE WORK AND NOW WE ARE
ACTUALLY BUILDING.
TAKES A LONG TIME.
WELL AGAIN THE BIG PROJECT THEIR
OBSTACLES THERE WERE FOR THE BAY
AREA RAPID TRANSIT SYSTEM FOR
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE IN THE
PANAMA CANAL.
A PASSOVER IN SILENCE THE TIME
IT TOOK TO BUILD THE THE BAY
AREA BRIDGE THAT WAS ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS.
AND BY THE WAY WAS OVER BUDGET
BY.
SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
WELL ONE BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT.
SO THAT HAPPENS.
BUT KNOW THE HIGH SPEED RAIL WE
GOT THAT WOULD COVER.
BUT BUILDING TODAY DID PULL
THOSE PROJECTS A BILL THAT WE
WILL AMERICA'S FIRST HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM.
ONE LINK BETWEEN CITIZENS HIM
CISCO AND ELECTRIFY CALTRAIN IS
FINANCE AND READY TO GO.
ANOTHER BILLION WITH MATCHING
FUNDS WILL BE INVEST IN LOS
ANGELES TO IMPROVE UNION STATION
AS A MAJOR TRANSPORTATION HUB
AND FIX THE ANAHEIM CORD.
CLINICS THERE IS COMPLETING THE
BALLOT SEGMENT
AND GETTING OPERATING SYSTEM
CONNECTED TO SAN JOSE YES ACOSTA
LOT OF MONEY BUT IT'S STILL
CHEAPER AND MORE CONVENIENT THAN
EXPANDING AIRPORTS WHICH NOBODY
WANTS TO DO. AND BUILDING NEW
FREEWAYS.
WHICH LANDOWNERS OFTEN OBJECTTO
ALL THAT IS TO MEET THE GROWING
DEMAND. WILL BE FAST THAT ICE ME
REAL BE FAST AND BE QUIET YOU'D
BE POWERED BY RULE ELECTRICITY
AND BEST OF ALL IN THE LAST FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS.
AFTER ALL YOU GUYS ARE GONE.
WARRANTED MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS OR
ON THE JOB AT SEVENTEEN SITES
AND HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES GENERATING THOUSANDS OF
JOB YEARS OF EMPLOYMENT.
AS THE GLOBAL ECONOMY PUTS MORE
AMERICANS OUT OF WORK AND LOWERS
WAGES INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
LIKE THIS WILL BE A KEY SOURCE.
A WELL PAID CALIFORNIA JOBS.
DIFFICULTIES CHALLENGES.
WHERE THEY GET DISCOURAGED OR
STOP US
WHETHER IT'S ROADS OR TRAINS OR
DAMS OR RENEWABLE ENERGY
INSTALLATIONS OR ZERO EMISSION
CARS? CALIFORNIA IS SETTING THE
PACE FOR THE ENTIRE NATION.
YEAH YES THEIR CRITICS
THEIR LAWSUITS LOTS OF THEM.
AND THERE COUNTLESS OBSTACLES
BUT CALIFORNIA WAS BUILT ON
DREAMS AND PERSEVERANCE AND THE
BOULDER PATH IS STILL OUR WAY
FORWARD.
MUSICIAN DO INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PHYSICAL INVESTMENTS
CALIFORNIA SPENDS HUGE SUMS
FIRST SERVICES WHICH OF.
THE FACT PEOPLE DIRECTLY SUCH AS
EDUCATION HEALTHCARE AND OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IN EDUCATION. THAT TO SINK
THIRTY THOUSAND TEACHERS LAID
OFF SPENDING HAS DRAMATICALLY
RECOVERED. INCREASING BY FORTY
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS PER STUDENT
THIRTY ONE BILLION OVERALL.
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO COMPLETELY
FUND THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH DIRECTS MONEY. TO
THOSE SCHOOLS WITH THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES.
FOR DECADES.
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD WIDELY
DISPARATE FUNDING INTO THE
SERRANO AGAINST PRIEST DECISION
MANDATED EQUAL FUNDING FOR ALL
CHILDREN.
NOW WITH OUR CURRENT FORMULA THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS
WILL GET SUBSTANTIALLY MORE NOT
JUST EQUAL FUNDING.
IMPORTANTLY THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO LINK SPENDING. WITH
A LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS SO
THAT PARENTS CAN SEE HOW THE
ADDITIONAL SPENDING SUPPORTS
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME FROM FAMILIES.
BUT IT'S NO SECRET THE KIDS FROM
MORE PRIVILEGED BACKGROUNDS
GENERALLY DO BETTER ON
STANDARDIZED TESTS.
BUT THE ANSWER IS NOT MORE MICRO
MANAGEMENT WITH INTRUSIVE STATE
LAWS
LEARNING TAKES PLACE IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND THAT'S WHY OUR
FIRST JOB IS TO SUPPORT TEACHERS
AND GIVEN THE TRAINING AND THE
FREEDOM TO TEACH BECAUSE THEY
KNOW BETTER
.
RESPECT TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
CLEAR HOW MUCH OF OUR PROSPERITY
DEPENDS ON THE INTELLECTUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS OR IN SOME.
IS OF HIGHER LEARNING.
NATIONAL LEADERS.
COME FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD TO
VISIT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES
COMPANIES THEY'RE FILLED. WITH
HIGHLY EDUCATED AND CREATIVE MEN
WOMEN. MANY OF WHOM GRADUATED
FOR A PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
ALTHOUGH IS ALWAYS A STRUGGLE
FOR FUNDS.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THIS IS%
TWENTY ELEVEN THE STATE HAS
INCREASED ITS ANNUAL SUPPORT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. BY FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION.
THAT'S ON INYO BASIS FROM NOW
ON.
THAT IS ONE POINT TWO BILLION
FOR YOU SEE. ONE POINT SIX
BILLION FOR CS YOU TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND SIX SEVEN TWENTY THREE
MILLION ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
AID.
BUT.
NEXT GO JUMP G..
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION.
HE WAS SO MANY OF ARE STUDENTS
ATTENDINGCOLLEGE THERE'S STILL
TWO AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
AND THIRTY FOUR WHO ARE IN THE
WORKFORCE BUT LACKED. A POST
SECONDARY DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN OFTEN GO OUT
OF STATE AND PAY HIGH TUITION AT
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS TO
IMPROVE THEIR SKILLS
EMPLOYABILITY. FOR THIS GROUP.
I WANT TO CREATE.
THE CALIFORNIA ONLINE COLLEGE
SO THESE OVERLOOKED CALIFORNIANS
CAN GET THE TRAINING THEY NEED
CONVENIENTLY AT A VERY LOW COST.
YOU CAN APPLAUD THAT I'M.
IN THIS ONE.
WE SOON COMPETE WITH BRICKS AND
MORTAR SCHOOLS OR THE EXISTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR YOU SEE
ARE YOU S. C. FIZBER PEOPLE OUT
OF THE WORKFORCE WEB NO THE WAY.
THAT WE WANT TO BRING IT RIGHT
TO THEIR HOMES SO THEY CAN GET
HERE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH CARE.
WHEN IT COMES BILL CARE HELD A
CALIFORNIA'S BOLDLY EMBRACE THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT BUT IN
RULING FIVE MILLION MORE PEOPLE
INTO A MEDICAL PROGRAM AND ONE
POINT THREE MILLION INTO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EXCHANGE.
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
THESE ARE FAR REACHING.
THESE THESE ARE REALLY FAR
REACHING MOVES WATER LARGELY
DEPENDED ON TENS OF BILLIONS OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THE WOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN AWAY
BY THE CONGRESS AND THE EFFORT
TO REPEAL AND REPLACE SUCCEEDED.
THANK GOD FOR JOHN MCCAIN. LISA
MURKOWSKI AND SUSAN COLLINS
ALONG WITH THE DEMOCRATS THEY
PREVAILED AND PROJECTED THE
HEALTH CARE FOR TENS OF MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS.
WILLINGLY.
OWN TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
NOTHING IS MORE IN FUNDAMENTAL.
THEN IN A BITING SENSE ON THE
PART OF PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN
ENJOY THEIR LIVES SAFE AND
SECURE.
FREE FROM CRIME. GOOD
NEIGHBORHOODS GOOD SCHOOLS AND
GOOD JOBS ALL CONTRIBUTE TO
HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES BUT
THERE STILL IS CRIME. LOTS OF IT
IN MANY CASES QUITE SERIOUS.
TO COMBAT CRIME AMONG OTHER
THINGS CALIFORNIA'S CREATED AN
EXTENSIVE PRISON SYSTEM
THAT IS CHANGE QUITE
SUBSTANTIALLY AND GROWN OVER THE
DECADES.
IN FACT HE GREW SO FAST IT
BECAME SO CROWDED THAT UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT ISSUED AN
UNPRECEDENTED ORDER REQUIRING
DRASTIC CHANGES.
DID GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE THE PROBLEM.
HERE'S SOME OF THE FACTS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
CALIFORNIA PRISON ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVEPERSONS PRODUCE
THOUSAND.
THAT NUMBER NOW STANDS AT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE.
THE CORRECTIONS BUDGET THEN WAS
ABOUT THREE PERCENT. OF THE
GENERAL FUND NOTES  POINT
NINE PERCENT ABOUT TWELVE
BILLION.
YET LAST YEAR THE NUMBER OF
REPORTED FELONIES WAS ACTUALLY
LOWER THAN IT WAS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE HEADED
BUT.
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND WORDS.
I ACTUALLY GOT TO PEOPLE
ACCOUNT.
TODAY THAT NUMBER HAS GROWN TO
ONE POINT TWO MILLION.
BY COMPARISON. THE TEN
COMMANDMENTS RUN JUST UNDER
THREE HUNDRED WORDS.
ONLY TEN COMMANDMENTS IS STILL
TEN.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND SEPARATE CRIMINAL
PROVISIONS
SO US ONE WHAT IS CRIMINAL WHAT
THE PENALTY SHOULD BE. WHAT
ENHANCEMENT SHOULD BE ADDED AND
WHAT CREDITS MIGHT BE BR?
MUCH OF THIS HAS CHANGED.
I'D SAY CHANGE OVER OVER AGAIN
AND TURNED OVER THE DECADES AS
THE LEGISLATURE IS INACTIVE
ENLIST NEW CRIME LAWS AND THE
VOTERS HAVE APPROVED ONE BALLOT
MEASURE AFTER ANOTHER. USUALLY
BUT NOT ALWAYS ADDING MORE TIME
IN PRISON.
MY PLEA IS RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD TAKE TIME TO
UNDERSTAND OUR SYSTEM A CRIME
AND PUNISHMENT HAS INVOLVED HOW
OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES HAVE
DEVISED THEIR PRISON SYSTEM.
AND WHAT CHANGES MIGHT WE KNOW
ME.
I URGE INSTEAD OF ENACTING NEW
LAWS BECAUSE A HORRIBLE CRIMES
AND LURID HEADLINES YOU CONSIDER
THE OVERALL SYSTEM.
AND WHAT IT MIGHT NEED A WHAT
TRULY PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
CERTAINLY WE NEED MORE MENTAL
HEALTH AND DRUG TREATMENT
PROGRAMS.
AND BETTER TRAINED. IMAGES.
THOSE WERE GETTING.
WHAT MORE IS NEEDED?
PARTICULARLY HOPE.
OPENS YOU KNOW IS ONE OF THE
THEOLOGICAL VIRTUES ALONG WITH
FAITH AND CHARITY.
ONE HUMAN BEING GETS A TWENTY OR
FORTY YEAR SENTENCE AS TENS OF
THOUSANDS DO INCENTIVES TO
REFORM WEAKENED. AND
HOPELESSNESS AND VIOLENCE
TAKEOVER MAKING PRISON GANG
INFLUENCE ALL THE MORE POWERFUL.
THAT'S WHY RECENT MEASURES ARE
SO VITAL WHICH ALLOW THE
POSSIBILITY IN ONLY THE
POSSIBILITY OF EARLIER PAROLE
AND MILESTONE CREDITS FOR THOSE
WHO TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT OR THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS WHO WALKED
THE HALLS IT PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE IN DIRECT CONTACT WITH
ALL MANNER OF IN ME.
THEIR JOB IS TO KEEP THE PLACE
SAFE. NEVER AN EASY TASK.
INTEGRATE IN THE ATMOSPHERE OF
RESPECT IN ORDER IN FOSTER A
SPIRITED REHABILITATION WHENEVER
POSSIBLE.
THERE THOUSAND OTHERS WHO WORK
IN THE PRISONS WHO ALSO DESERVE
OUR SUPPORT.
IT'S ALL OUT OF SIGHT.
BUT PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
INMATES WILL BE RETURNING TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES
MOST A MORAL. AND WE WANT THEM
TO BE AS REFORM AND
REHABILITATED AS POSSIBLE.
FOR THE REST.
TWO IS MUCH WE CAN DO TOGETHER
BEFORE THIS YEAR ENDS.
AND THESE ARE TRULY EXCITING
TIMES FULL OF POSSIBILITIES.
BUT ALSO FULL OF DANGER JUST
THIS MORNING. THE PREEMINENT
SCIENCE AND SECURITY BOARD OF
THE BULLETIN OF THE ATOMIC
SCIENTISTS
MOVE THE MINUTE HAND OF THE
DOOMSDAY CLOCK THIRTY SECONDS
CLOSER. TO CATASTROPHE
IS NOW TWO MINUTES TO MIDNIGHT
AS CLOSE AND IT WAS AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE.
OUR WORLD. OUR WAY OF LIFE. OUR
SYSTEM OF GOVERNANCE OR ARE AN
IMMEDIATE AND GENUINE RISK.
ANALYST NEW WEAPONS SYSTEMS
GROWING ANTAGONISM AMONG NATIONS
THE POISON IN OUR POLITICS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ALL OF THE SCHOOLS OUT FOR
COURAGE FOR IMAGINATION.
AND FOR GENEROUS DIALOGUE.
IN RECENT DAYS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TOOK TO THE STREETS
THE CITIES ACROSS AMERICA TO
PURCHASE A PLATE IN THE WOMAN'S
MARCH.
AT THE SAME TIME ACTIVISTS
CHAMPION THE CAUSE OF THE
NATION'S CAPITAL OF THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE WE CALL THE DREAMERS.
AND ALL THIS CALIFORNIA WAS IN
THE FOREFRONT SHOWING THE WAY.
BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE TO DO.
MUCH MORE TO DO ALL OF US
WHATEVER OUR PARTY OR PHILOSOPHY
A RULE TO PLAY. IN DEFINING AND
ADVANCING OUR DEMOCRACY.
OUR FOREBEARS SET THE EXAMPLE IS
YOU MAY KNOW MY OWN GREAT
GRANDFATHER ALL YOU SHUFFLING IN
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE SAILED TO
AMERICA ON A SHIP. NAME
PERSEVERANCE
HE PERSISTED
AGAINST ALL THE ODDS AND MADE TO
SACRAMENTO THREE YEARS LATER.
AND YES.
WE TOO WILL PERSIST BEGINS
STORMS IN TURMOIL OBSTACLES
DRAYTON SMALL.
THE SPIRIT OF DEMOCRACY NEVER
DIES IT'S ALIVE IN THIS CHAMBER
IN THE HEARTS OF CALIFORNIANS IN
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. LET
THIS BE A GREAT YEAR FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR NATION AND
FOR OUR FUTURE.
THANK YOU
NO.
THANK YOU GOVERNOR THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE GOVERNOR
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS FROM
THE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL AS A
SEPARATE APPENDIX WE WILL
ADJOURN THE JOINT CONVENTION
SIGNING DIE.
WE ARE BACK IN REGULAR SESSION
THE SET SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY
NINTH FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
MS GARCIA MOVES MISTER BONTA
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH AT ONE PM QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED